hey Doug Walker here again people asked
about the shirt this is a mr. bill shirt
oh so sorry just got that out there some
because sometimes you only see like the
top hat if you're like what the hell is
that so that's what that is
but I just saw the first purge the film
called the first pert you know what
that's I know it's re good cause a lot
of confusion but if you clicked on this
video you know what you're watching and
a video an aesthetic video literally
just went out of me talking about kind
of how the purge movies get better so
just real quick I'll tell you my
thoughts on the first three that came
before this first film I think is awful
I think it's a terrible terrible film I
loved the idea I feel like they don't
take advantage of it and there's a ton
of plot holes second film gets a lot
better the kind of wreck on some of the
problems in the first so I'm like
there's still some issues with it but it
gets a lot better you can see the world
and see how it works and then the third
film I think is a legit kind of good
movie like that nothing fantastic but I
mean like it's sort of it sort of takes
in a direction I feel like these movies
really should have done where it's kind
of both you know can't this exploitation
gorefest but also can have this
political angle that would like a lot of
exploitation films kind of do but but it
happens almost a little bit more
naturally it doesn't feel quite as far
as day it was good suspense good
characters and stuff so they tend to get
better as they go along and now we have
this one this is a prequel called the
first purge which shows you know how it
happened pretty much and it's um it's a
mixed bag and I say that because like a
lot of the stuff in it is some of the
best stuff I've seen in any of the purge
movies from like the violence and the
satire and the commentary and the
characters and some of its I can't see
the worst because we still have the
original purge film still that's like
the worst stuff for me but but
definitely some of some of the least
stuff about it stuff like you know like
the acting is very split like some of it
is really really good and then
other parts you kind of go what why did
they pick this person well why is this
person talking this way nobody talks
this way same thing with the writing
like some of the dialogue will be you
know they'll be these really good lines
I'm just like oh man that's a like I
gotta commit that to memory that's a
good line and then other things where
you're just like really we're going with
this so it's very half and half the if
you want the cliff note version real
fast I'm glad I saw it I don't think
it's the worst purge movie I don't think
it's the best but I do think it has kind
of like the worst and best elements in
it so I'm still very happy I saw it but
yes the sort get into the nitty-gritty
of it it does not go too much into the
politics of how we came to be at least
why it starts out it's something like a
couple days before the first purge is
gonna start and at first I didn't like
that I wanted to see kind of you know
people in suits talking about how
they're gonna do this and stuff like
that but then the more I thought about
it I'm kinda glad they didn't because I
think it would've been too predictable
if anything the way this works is it
kind of works backwards where the purge
is gonna happen and then you see kind of
its kind of like Hunger Games where you
see the people watching and they're kind
of trying to figure out what's going on
and why it's going on or why something
isn't going on and then they kind of
correct it corrected you know in their
own way which again if you've seen the
other purge movies it's there's no real
surprises in this but you know it does
kind of show how some of these things it
came about why the purge technically
doesn't work but with that said like as
soon as it starts out like the act I
first thought crap this is gonna suck
this is gonna be awful because like you
just have these two incredibly hokey
actors talking back and forth with
close-ups like this they're talking this
close to the camera I'm just like at
least we'll have a so bad it's good
movie you know kind of thing but then
like I said they it it goes back and
forth with everything like even it opens
with all these uh after the title shows
there shows all the all this news cover
about how the world is in shambles and
stuff it's the year our shop Inaba
because the time line makes no sense in
these movies even in the first film they
make no goddamn sense and now you can
tell they're just throwing it out the
window like we don't know and this is
the x-men movies now you know that we
know this makes no sense but uh so
source shows like again almost hitting
the nail a little too hard on the head
because a lot of the stuff they're
showing is like real protest videos of
stuff that's happened over the past
couple years and even further so you
know they're trying to harken a little
bit on like this stuff that's going on
now but it it doesn't quite go too far
like you know it when it shows the
president they don't make a punk like
Trump there's no Trump hat like what
they showed on the posters or anything
like that there's one really stupid joke
where like somebody like when the purge
starts like somebody's trying to like
you know but grabbed this woman it gets
close to her crotch and she uses mace to
game off and says you know it she says
like grabbed a and
it's like yeah it's just as good as you
know in Jurassic world following Kingdom
when the guy called the hipster woman a
nasty woman like subtle like shut like
and that's what's so weird because like
with these movies I know it's supposed
to kind of be in your face but then some
of them you're really like will you just
shut up like I do political jokes too
but it's like sometimes just those
hammers on the head are so painful but
what's so weird about that is that a lot
of the political angles with this I
found really really interesting because
a lot of it is about it's not everywhere
it doesn't start off everywhere in
America it only starts off on Stan
Island which is interesting and this is
gonna be like their experiment and what
they do is that not they because it is
technically an experiment they pay
people that want to take part in the
experiment and they give them these
little cameras these little contact
lenses which creates this great effect
where they glow and it gives some good
creepy imagery that comes from that and
so again that there's sort of an
exploitation angle
two of like you know well they're paying
these people to kind of kill each other
and partake in this terrible thing to
sort of but then there's also an angle
that there's like Canada's politician
and the scientist they're the ones are
kind of keeping an eye on everything and
the scientist really is doing it mostly
for the science even though it's it's
kind of it's a psychotic idea you know
it's still you know but she really is in
it you know because the research has
shown this and and my numbers have shown
this so this should happen so the
build-up to this is probably the best of
any of the purge movies because you know
everyone's kind of talking so our people
can do anything or is this gonna be
chaos or is everyone just gonna fool the
system and not do a thing or it just
what's gonna happen and you really feel
this dread you see like everyone just
kind of preparing for this but not like
in the other movies where it's like
they're all just happy smiles and they
just get their security system which I
mean I that's got its own commentary too
but I mean you see them like you know
getting ready just in case really
does go down and some people preparing
to do some crimes and stuff like that
and you know some some psychos they're
gonna go crazy and stuff and you got
kind of this one protester who's really
trying to you know be against it and a
lot of people are against it but some
people are for it and you see the
different reasons why some people are
signing up to do the purge you know some
is for money others are just for they
want to get revenge on somebody and the
political guys the politicians I mean
it's already kinda obvious why they want
to do it but you know they say the
reason in the opening and then they get
more to the main reason later which
again if you know the other purge movies
that they it's not a huge surprise and
then when the purge starts it's not
working you know and like only a couple
tests are happening it's mostly just
robberies and getting money or you know
just my favorite is they're building up
these two kind of crazy ladies who are
like you know they're just putting
around these shopping carts with like
fireworks and stuff in little dolls
better go
what do they have in mind again
without giving it away it's just it's
it's just a pure lap it's a pure these
are just two crazy ladies and it was
really really funny but and people are
throwing parties and stuff like that and
again you got some people that are
trying to get revenge and it's kind of
cool when they in the other movies when
they really explore the world and you
have kind of the people like you know I
figure what they're calling it not the
freedom fighters but but something like
that
where they fight against the people who
do the purge you know they try to
protect others and stuff you kind of see
where that starts and I like that I kind
of like seeing where some of these
things get going and where they come
from even though they're they're not
surprising but they're still cool to see
uh but then you got stuff like the
biggest problem with this movie is the
tone because which is always kind of
been an issue with the purge movies by
me for the most part it's like it wants
to be creepy disturbing and it like an
exploitation movie and like I said the
first one I didn't think really worked
on that but but they got better as they
went along and this one still has that
exploitation angle down but then they'll
do stuff like they'll throw in this
comic relief like you know this
middle-aged woman who just does not fit
in this world at all I mean this is
something like at the very end people
are shot and they're bleeding and stuff
and she's totally fine she does have a
scratch on there she's just like I have
had one hell of a night like you know
don't cross me and it's like it's that
and it's sort of the acting on
her isn't even really that great I mean
cuz like that they're reunited at one
point she comes in and and they just see
her and you know you think you know it
hurt beery and I were a friend you think
she'd be like oh just this big sigh of
relief and and she could still say some
funny stuff but she it's just like I
have had a hell of a time getting here
and it's like really like after all this
intense imagery and really suspenseful
action scenes like you're gonna throw in
this character on top of that the the
main protestor in the
movie is this very uninteresting
monotone that just and she's supposed to
be like the badass like she's the one
that's like you know yeah I've held a
gun before
yeah I've had a boyfriend yeah no we're
not going without you it's just kind of
this monotone that maybe in another
movie would work but like here it really
doesn't but on top of that I'm just
gonna go throw I'd serve all the bad
actors remember or at least people that
were not directed in a convincing way
the talks in the opening we're like that
the newscaster is talking to the
politician about and the scientists
about how this purge is supposed to work
and it like first of all no reporter
from an actual like news program like a
legit news program we can't talk like
this just uh huh yeah well I see what
you're trying to sell me there but what
we say about blah blah blah and the only
news programs that talk like that or
sort of like if the beach schlocky wants
like CNN or Fox News and stuff like that
and this guy did not have that schlock
talked down like you kind of see these
schlock reporters and you know it's like
I am here to exploit this story as much
as possible yeah but what are you really
trying to say and this guy didn't talk
late and say well I see where you're
trying to give me there but what exactly
is going on with this and yadda yadda
okay well now do you really believe that
yadda and it it doesn't work like if
you're gonna be a schlock reporter pH
Lok reporter go for the you know I want
my face in the center I want to be as
big a part of the story is what I'm
covering I won't be the focus of the
story you know everybody seen those
reporters and you think these movies
will be great at showing that you know
like The Hunger Games you know it's like
kind of the same thing with those over
the top of the personalities and hosts
and stuff like that but and then you
have the politicians especially the main
guy who's like really trying to who
works for the nffa in this and again
he's trying to be that but it's just
kind of awkward and weird like he just
he's not in the same movie that like the
main characters are in you know he's
they're talking like this yes the purge
will be great and we will see a new dawn
in there like it sounds weird but then
you see like the main characters like
the main dude and there's
like you know he's head of this gang but
he's trying to keep peace and he just
seems totally legit like he is really in
this war zone and he's got to keep his
head and he's got to keep an eye out for
who's gonna betray him and who is in
he's gotta keep control and you just
feel every decision he's making like he
just feels like a 100% real person and
then you kind of cut to these you know
like this very awkwardly acted
politician you know or this awkward
newscaster or this awkward you know and
a badass girl I was supposed to like you
know be fighting against them and so
it's a lot of stuff like that
or the crazy guy there's a he's called
Skeletor and like Eber for just schlocky
over the top I'm crazy who you know like
drool coming up I just wasn't buying it
like it wasn't sometimes I get a laugh
at how kind of awkward it was and I
don't blame the actors when that stuff
happens because it's like it's it's very
tough to when you're really playing
crazy you're supposed to play in a movie
like this like you really gotta trust
the director like what am I giving what
this is supposed to look like you know
kind of thing so so I don't know like
there's a lot of pieces that weren't
fitting together but like those pieces
on their own were very interesting
because like I said at first the the
purge isn't really working or not
working how they how they wanted to so
again if you see the other movies you
kind of know it's gonna lead to the
government intervening and you see more
and more what they're trying to do and I
feel like it could have stopped there
they didn't really have to over explain
it but they do a little bit when the
politician the scientists are talking
which again the scientist senses senses
something is up
and doesn't want false results I really
like that I like even though this is a
crazy-ass idea it's like she's still
like no this I want the actual results I
want the real numbers and the
politicians are steps in saying why he's
intervening and it's it's obvious why
and even though what he says isn't like
laughably bad or anything it's not
needed so so you got all that you have
that for the political angle and then
you sort of have the
you know the violent gory angle as well
which it's kind of a slow burn but it
buddy gets to it and it starts off
pretty intense there's a really great
fight sequence in like a stairwell that
it's almost done in one shot but they've
cut it up and it's it's not a big deal
but it's done really fast really intense
I'm just watching that against the main
character and he is just whooping ass in
this scene and it's such a cool moment
and is it at a part where the movie is
starting to get boring that kind of
elevates it again it's just like okay
let's I'm kind of back into this I'm
ready to get back into this film and
then they do this really weird thing
where something happens in the building
where the lights go off and they'll come
out for a second and then off for like
two and then on for a second then off
for two it's like well okay they get a
few good shots with that like somebody's
there then it goes off and then they're
a little closer and then it goes off you
know he's hiding in the shadow so and
the creepy masks that they have and
stuff so it's like they take advantage
of that a little bit but then like it's
throughout the whole climax and it gets
so annoying so fast and even the climax
itself when you compare it to the other
films I mean to the first the original
films credit in man that's re causing
confusion to the original film's credit
the first one that came out you know it
did build to a climax it's like what's
predictable but it's like okay well
that's that's a legit climax that's kind
of where you feel like the story should
go and the other ones do to this one
kind of like okay what just ends on
another action sequence and it doesn't
feel like it really bill to anything you
know until the final line which again is
building up where this is all gonna go
and again I feel like the dread in this
movie is I can't I'm going back and
forth and all this but there's so many
good things and so many bad things the
dread is so good in this because they're
constantly talking about you know is
this gonna be like the future is this
gonna be like what it is it's like no
this really isn't this isn't gonna
happen and it doesn't feel too Winky you
know like it really feels like you know
it's gonna fail you know this is like
what the future is gonna be and and it's
tough to watch all these people
preparing
you know we're trying to do good or
trying to you know people hiding in
churches and like holding on to their
kids and stuff it is like yeah but like
this is intense like this is really
suspenseful you know when it starts up
and and when people aren't doing
anything or they are doing something I
mean you don't you don't know this world
yet you feel much more that uncertainty
even though you know the direction the
world is gonna go there's much more
uncertainty because you also know the
way the government's gonna intervene so
it's very cleverly done by the time the
first movie starts it's kind of like
well this world's already established
you know how it works it's just gonna be
a home invasion movie and a pretty tall
one at that with the exception of a guy
trying to get in but yeah with this one
there is a weirdly enough even though
it's a prequel there's a little bit more
of an unpredictability of like well how
many people are gonna participate in how
many aren't and what's you know the
numbers say this but what's actually
gonna happen uh so yeah it's it's served
these really intense two sides going at
each other of like really good acting
and really good commentary good satire a
good action and then just this other
side of really hokey acting super
obvious commentary I mean even down to a
point where that they play the America
vivo coup at one point and they have
like you know just some of the imagery
is just so over the top you know in what
they're trying to imply and then you'll
also have like annoying comic relief and
you'll have action sequences where the
lights are just blinking and it gets
really annoying so it's it's really
tough it's it's tough to say what I
think of this film because like I said
I'm I'm still happy I saw it I'm still
really happy that like that this is kind
of a good at least half of this movie
it's exactly where I wanted these movies
to go this in many respects really
should have been the first movie like
with this concept I'm like I would be
you really can just skip the original
purge movie I mean it is just so
pointless it's just looking back on all
these films I'm like yeah there you can
start with this one and then go to purge
anarchy in the purge election year
like that totally works you can just
100% skip the ethan hawke to move you're
not missing a thing except for the
leader if again the Henry guy I know
he's not Henry but that's not his name
but that's what I called him I don't
care so yeah I if you like these movies
or or even start to like them it's it's
just interesting enough some people
because some of the commentary does get
very you know in your face
I feel like that'll probably that might
upset a few people or and some which I
it's good to get upset some would say
it's it's way too obvious or too preachy
but I think you kind of know that's got
to be a little bit of an angle like
there's I like these I like the ones
that feel a little bit more like an
exploitation movie and and even in a
strange way when it does get so obvious
with the commentary and it does
obviously date it I feel like that also
kind of gives it its own identity like
it's some exploitation films of the past
like you know what they're commenting on
at that time but that's kind of their
charm too but again because they're
trying to throw so much at you and only
about half of it is working I I don't
know if that's gonna make it stay long
cuz there is almost a timeless element
to this idea actually I found my dad was
just tell me apparently there's a Star
Trek episode they had the same idea so
if there is kind of a timeless element I
guess but yeah but then when you mix in
stuff that obviously it's gonna cement
it this was the year this came out or
this time period this came out it it
does kind of distract a little bit so I
feel like it's it's strange in some
areas it goes too far in some areas not
far enough it's very odd but when it
does hit I really really like it it's
like I said this is kind of the
uncomfortable but awesome exploitation
film I want to see with this idea if
somebody tells me this idea this is kind
of the movie I expect to see out of a
crime is legal one night a year you know
and this is how it starts this is kind
of the movie I want to see this is kinda
how I want
see a go at least half of it I really
feel like there's the other half that
needs work and sometimes it is laughably
bad but but it's not god-awful it's it's
like just annoying enough I mean there's
no actor where I'm just like oh my god
you there are comic relief is pretty
annoying and Skeletor is pretty annoying
like I feel like especially with
Skeletor you get a hand like a really
cool character like a really everybody
would remember this guy but they didn't
have a clear vision for him and maybe
that's it maybe some elements like they
really did have a clear vision of what
they want to do with it and then others
it's like well let's try this because
we've seen it work in other films but we
don't really have an idea of what the
end product is gonna be so it kind of
feels like that but I'm still glad I saw
it if you like the other purge films I
say definitely check it out it's I can't
guarantee you'll like it but there's
still enough interesting things in there
that I feel it's kind of warranted to
see but yeah it's when it doesn't work
it does feel gimmicky I'm not even
kidding in the credits there's an ad for
the TV show like if first I thought was
a satire because you know there's a lot
of satire in these movies but it's a
legit commercial for a future TV show
about the purge on USA and that's
painful man that is just like how it
becomes so hard to say yeah go see this
movie when there was a literal
commercial for your TV show in there
like that just like in the credits it's
kind of cringy so so I don't know it's
it's cringy in the waist it's supposed
to be cringy and cream cheese and cringy
in the waves it's not supposed to be
cream cheese so I know it's kind of all
over the map I know it's kind of
scatterbrain but I would still say if
you like these movies I would still say
go see it I can't guarantee you'll love
it
but I think you'll get some good stuff
out there's still some cool scenes some
cool visuals and ideas like there's just
cool concepts and ideas in there and
that's what I really feel the original
purge movie was missing it was just one
idea and then just never exploited like
it like exploited for the
exploitation film you're supposed to be
so um yeah that's about it take a look
tell me what you think I'm really
curious what people think of this movie
I like the ones that follow the purge
films because if you if you're not
following them you're not gonna see this
one I mean I I doubt you're good just
you know I should just check this out
like just this one film it's like no
you're probably gonna see the others and
have your thoughts on them or or in some
way be a fan of them and yeah I'm
curious how this film goes over with
fans so that's about it and I shall talk
to you next time late
you